[Musique]
pendant le temps des fêtes chacun
d'entre vous va dépenser environ 600
dollars entre la nourriture et les
cadeaux et qui dit cadeau dit emballages
ça c'est une industrie qui récupère des
millions $ à cette période de l'année
près de 99 millions de dollars pour être
précis et même si on sait très bien
qu'ils vont finir déchiré en quelques
secondes ou dans nos poubelles
la plupart d'entre nous passent beaucoup
de temps à faire le plus bel emballage
possible mais ce que vous vous êtes déjà
posé la question de savoir quand cette
manie d'emballer pineau cadeaux avaient
vraiment commencé l'emballage des
cadeaux ça existe depuis des siècles
littéralement
et c'est une tradition qui viendrait
d'asie parce que c'est là qu'il faut
regarder si on veut voir les premières
techniques d'emballage apparaître
d'abord en chine dans la dynastie des
song du sud vers le xième siècle les
cadeaux étaient donnés dans des
enveloppes appelé shibao un genre de
papier d'emballage fait de chanvre de
fibres de bambou et de paille de riz
il y a aussi le beau gadji coréen cette
technique date de la période des trois
royaumes de corée sans doute dès le
premier siècle
il faut broder ces pièces pour en faire
un patchwork
alors à moins d'être un expert de la
couture la technique reste un peu
compliqué au japon dans les années 16
cents on utilisait le furent au chi chi
une étoffe d'emballage réutilisables en
occident il faut attendre quelques
siècles de plus pour voir apparaître la
mode de l'emballage cadeau on emballe
les présents dès l'époque victorienne
dont vers le début du 19e siècle s'est
d'abord vu comme quelque chose de
luxueux les bourgeois de l'époque
victorienne utilise alors du papier de
tissus décoratifs des rubans et de la
dentelle pour emballer leurs cadeaux de
la façon la plus somptueuse possible car
c'est un signe de richesse au début du
20e siècle on utilise surtout du papier
tissu souvent colorés en rouge vert et
blanc
mais c'est en 1910 est ce que le papier
décoratifs se démocratise réellement
l'idée elle vient de deux frères qui
était à la tête d'une compagnie
d'articles de papeterie al marque et qui
connaissait une saison particulièrement
prolifique durant en effet leurs papiers
tissu n'a pas tenu le choc stocks
épuisés
pas de problème ils ont remplacé par du
papier français de fantaisie qu'ils ont
commencé à vendre pour 10 m de dollars
américains la feuille il récidive
l'expérience en 1918 puis en 1919 avec à
chaque fois un franc succès et c'est
comme ça qu'il décide de lancer un
véritable commerce du papier emballage
papier imprimé ruban décoratifs dès les
années 30
l'industrie de l'emballage est né il y à
101 ans on est passé du papier journal
tissu ou autres papiers bien simple est
recyclable à cette industrie
grandissante de l'emballage fantaisie et
sophistiquée et tout ça prend encore
plus d'essor au moment de l'avènement de
la société de consommation de masse dans
les années 50 60
juste après les années de vaches maigres
de la seconde guerre mondiale fini les
pénuries le pouvoir d'achat des ménages
augmente et avec ça le visage de noël
change et c'est la course effrénée dans
les grands magasins
c'est l'image du nouveau noël
traditionnel des airs de bing crosby une
dinde aux canneberges et sous le sapin
de l'électroménager pour maman un rasoir
pour papa et la montre mickey mouse pour
l'enfant le tout bien emballé en 1958 ce
petit film promotionnel lancé parole
marc montre l'art d'emballer avec à la
tête est la bonne ménagère
tellement démocratiser le papier qu'en
décembre 2016 les canadiens ont dépensé
près de 99 millions de dollars pour
acheter des cartes et du papier
d'emballage
ça c'est une augmentation de 85% par
rapport à la moyenne mensuelle le reste
de l'année mais on emballe pas seulement
pendant la période de noël en fait on
emballe pendant toute l'année pour des
anniversaires la saint-valentin
saint-nicolas pâques et parfois même on
emballe ce qui est déjà emballée